.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE."
ANYONE OF A CERTAIN AGE
REMEMBERS AN AD CAMPAIGN USED TO
PROMOTE TOURISM IN A
BELD
NEW YORK.
>> I LOVE YOUR FOREIGN ACCENT.
>> ♪ ♪
.
>> I LOVE THE WAY YOU PUT ON
A SHOW.
>> I LOVE NEW YORK.
>> THERE ARE MORE WAYS TO LOVE
NEW YORK THEN THERE ARE LIGHTS
ON BROADWAY.
>> ♪ ♪
>> I LOVE NEW YORK.
DO YOU KNOW WHY?
BECAUSE IT'S OPEN ALL NIGHT.
>> Laura: WELL, THAT WAS BACK IN
THE 1980s.
CELEBRITIES AND THE TOURISM
BOARD WORKED TO TRY TO SAVE NEW
YORK THAT WAS IN TROUBLE BACK
THEN.
IF THE CHAIRMAN OF THE BOARD
WERE ALIVE TODAY, I BET HE WOULD
START SPREADING A DIFFERENT TYPE
OF NEWS ABOUT NEW YORK.
FAR LEFT DEMOCRATS AT ALL LEVELS
OF GOVERNMENT ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR CRATERING A ONCE GREAT
AMERICAN CITY.
IT'S ABOUT TO GET A LOT WORSE
BECAUSE OF SOMETHING THE "ANGLE"
WARNED YOU ABOUT AT THE START OF
THE PANDEMIC.
THERE ARE PROPOSALS FOR IMMUNITY
PASSPORTS REQUIRED FOR
COMMERCIAL FLIGHTS OR TO GO TO
WORK.
>> DIGITAL CERTIFICATES THAT
CERTIFY THAT AMERICAN CITIZENS
HAVE AN IMMUNITY TO THIS VIRUS
TO FACILITATE TRAVEL AND WORK.
>> I AM CONCERNED ABOUT THE
SLIPPERY SLOPE WITH
ENCROACHMENTS ON PERSONAL
LIBERTY.
>> Laura: IN 14 PLUS MONTHS, THE
ONLY GROUP THAT HASN'T HAD ITS
LIBERTIES ENCROACHED UPON ON IN
NEW YORK ARE THE LOOTERS, THUGS
AND THE BANG -- GANG BANGERS WHO
ARE FREE TO TERRORIZE THE CITY.
DIMWIT BILL DE BLASIO DOESN'T
CARE.
>> BECAUSE SOMEONE IS VACCINATED
THEY CAN DO ALL OF THE AMAZING
THINGS AVAILABLE IN THIS CITY.
IT WILL REQUIRE VACCINATION FOR
WORKERS AND CUSTOMERS IN INDOOR
DINING AND FITNESS FACILITIES
AND ENTERTAINMENT FACILITIES.
THIS WILL BE A REQUIREMENT.
THE ONLY WAY TO PATRONNIZE THESE
TAKENMENTS INDOOR SIZE IF YOU
ARE VACCINATED.
--
>> Laura: THINK ABOUT THIS.
YOU ARE ONE OF THE BRAVE
RESTAURANTS THAT KEPT GOING
DESPITE THE OBSCENE LOCKDOWNS
AND RULES.
NOW THEY THROW UP THIS BARRIER
TO YOU AND YOUR CUSTOMER BASE.
FOR MOST OF THE PAST 18 MONTHS
NOW THE CITY HAS BEEN SUFFERING
UNDER COVID SHUTDOWNS AND
CRIMINALS HAVE A RUN OF THE
PLACE.
MAYOR DE BLASIO WANTS TO TAKE
THIS CITY BACKWARDS LIKE MAY OF
2020 BECAUSE OF THE DELTA
VARIANT.
IT'S THE LATEST EXCUSE FOR
MAKING LIFE MISERABLE FOR
BUSINESSES, STUDENTS AND SERVICE
INDUSTRY WORKERS.
I AM HEAR TO TELL YOU TONIGHT
WHAT DE BLASIO IS DOING HAS ZERO
TO DO WITH THE VIRUS.
I WANT YOU TO LOOK CLOSELY AT
THE DEATH CHART FROM COVID IN
NEW YORK STATE.
DOES THIS LOOK LIKE A CRISIS TO
YOU?
IF YOU LOOK AT NEW YORK CITY
ALONE, 8.3 MILLION PEOPLE, THE 7
DAY AVERAGE OF TOTAL DEATHS FROM
COVID RIGHT NOW IS 5.
ON APRIL 7, 2020, THAT NUMBER
WAS 815.
WE DON'T HAVE A COVID CRISIS IN
NEW YORK.
WE HAVE A LEADER CRISIS IN NEW
YORK.
PUTTING ASIDE WHAT WE KNOW IS
A GROSS DEPRIVATION OF LIBERTY
WHICH WILL BE CHALLENGED IN
COURT, THIS NEW NORMAL MANDATE
WILL BE ANOTHER STAKE IN THE
HEART OF A CITY STRUGGLING TO
SURVIVE.
THIS IS THE REALITY OF LIFE IN
NEW YORK CITY AFTER DE BLASIO'S
RAIN OF TERROR.
VACCINE PASSPORTS WILL ONLY HAVE
MORE NEW YORKERS ABANDONING THE
STATE.
IN TENNESSEE THEY ARE GOING ON
WITH THEIR LIVES.
DITTO WITH TEXAS, FLORIDA.
COVID CASES ARE GOING UP, BUT
THE GOVERNORS OF RED STATES
AMERICA KNOW THAT MANDATES,
THREATS AND RESTRICTIONS THEY
KILL THE PATIENT, MEANING THEIR
STATE'S ECONOMY AND THEIR
CHILDREN'S FUTURE.
THEY ALSO KNOW THE GOVERNMENT'S
REFUSAL TO RECOGNIZE THE
PROTECTIONS THAT MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS ALREADY
HAVE FROM NATURAL IMMUNITY SHOWS
THAT THIS IS NOT ABOUT SCIENCE.
THIS IS ABOUT POWER AND ABOUT
CONTROL.
BIDEN MAY NOT UNDERSTAND THE
DYNAMICS IN PLAY, BUT THE STARK
CONTRAST BETWEEN LIFE IN A FREE
STATE AND LIFE IN A COVID
CAPTIVE STATE, BIDEN'S POLITICAL
VENTRILOQUIST GET IT SO THEY
SENT OLD JOE OUT AGAIN TO ATTACK
DESANTIS AND ABBOTT.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THAT GOVERNOR
DESANTIS AND GOVERNOR ABBOTT ARE
HARMING THEIR OWN CITIZENS?
>> I BELIEVE THE RESULTS OF
THEIR DECISIONS ARE NOT GOOD FOR
THEIR CONSTITUENTS.
IT'S CLEAR TO ME AND TO MOST OF
THE MEDICAL EXPERTS THE
DECISIONS MADE LIKE NOT ALLOWING
MASK MANDATES IN SCHOOLS ARE BAD
HEALTH POLICY.
>> Laura: THE MEDICAL EXPERTS.
IN THE SPRING OF 2020 AND THE
FALL OF 2021, THE RED STATES
WILL ONCE AGAIN BEGIN TO LEAVE
THE BLUE STATES BEHIND.
WHY WOULD YOU START A NEW
BUSINESS TODAY THIS NEW YORK?
WHICH YOU COULD LIVE A NORMAL
LIFE IN NASHVILLE.
MORE AND MORE AMERICANS TRAPPED
IN BLUE STATES WILL SEE THEY
DON'T HAVE TO LIVE THIS WAY
ANYMORE.
UNLESS YOU ARE ITCHING TO IT
LIVE UNDER THESE TERMS:
SKY ROCKETING CRIME.
MURDERS AND SHOOTINGS WAY UP.
INSANE COVID RULES AND THE
ENTITLEMENT DEMOCRATS WANT TO
MAKE PERMANENT.
THE LOVE GOV LET IT SLIP.
>> I DON'T THINK WE GET BACK TO
NORMAL.
I THINK WE GET BACK TO OR WE GET
TO A NEW NORMAL.
RIGHT?
LIKE WE ARE SEEING SO MANY
FACETS OF SOCIETY RIGHT NOW.
WE WILL BE IN A DIFFERENT PLACE.
>> Laura: IF THERE IS A SHRED OF
PRINCIPLE IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, NOT MUCH OF A CHANCE OF
THAT.
WE WILL HAVE MORE ON THE
GOVERNOR LATER ON.
UNTIL THE VOTERS IN NEW YORK
DELIVER A REBUKE TO THE FAR
LEFT, THEY SHOULD EXPECT A NEW
NORMAL OF CONSTANT MISERY.
ANY CITY THAT FOLLOWS THEIR LEAD
WILL JOI